[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is a
delight Rory Scoville I think I said I
do say it in this episode I didn't want
to make him uncomfortable because it's
always weird when someone's like you are
my favorite stand-up comedian but Rory
Scoville is my favorite stand-up
comedian he's incredible this chat is
incredible and Rory is on tour currently
he's about it's about to start so if
you're listening to this the week it
comes out you are in in line potentially
to go see Rory live go to Rory Scoville
s-c-o-v-e-l.com and you can get tickets
to any of his shows honestly nothing
this sounds almost like romantic Nothing
Compares but nothing compares to seeing
Rory live so do yourself a favor one of
the best Live Comedy experiences you can
give yourself go to roryscovel.com and
check him out if he's coming to a town
near you and I'm sure he is uh I am also
on tour go to petehomes.com this is how
it works Rory Scoville Royce goble.com
Pete Holmes go to petehomes.com I just
I'm going to be adding even more dates
but I'm about to be in Nolan's I believe
I'm saying that correctly New Orleans
and then uh Dallas lots of lots of dates
I'm going all over the place so go to
petehomes.com if you would like to see
me there or if you're going to be in Los
Angeles go to
largo-la.com I have a monthly residency
at Largo which is always the highlight
of my month so you can see me there and
off and Rory there I often have Rory on
that show as well it's a go to
largo-la.com for that this show is
brought To Us by our friends at
magicmind for you guys that are new to
the show I only do ads for things that I
actually use and actually love and Magic
mind is I don't know it's it's the
product that I think has changed my my
life the most in the past year it is a
productivity drink it's not an energy
drink I'm always giving it to the guests
I'm always giving it to my friends
creative types and otherwise what is it
it's about 35 milligrams of caffeine
just a little bit of caffeine and it's
got adaptogens that help your body cope
with stress and it's got new atropics
like lion's mane that help your brain
function so it's nootropics adaptogens
and a little bit of caffeine so it's
wonderful if you're trying to drink less
coffee but it's also just wonderful if
you want to boost your mood boost your
productivity boost your energy and you
don't get uh wired you get dialed in
this is an absolute secret weapon for me
I always drink one before I do the
podcast I always drink one when I sit
down to answer emails dial into some
writing dial into a any amount of work
that is just feeling daunting the
adaptogens ease that stress so you
stress less and then you do more I
absolutely love it that's why I'm always
offering it to the guests and we have a
special discount if you go to
magicmind.com weird you'll get 20 off
your order fight off procrastination
brain fog fatigue and some ADD symptoms
and get into that up Flow State with
magic mind I absolutely love it
magicmine dot Co slash weird also
speaking of life-changing uh products
this is my Apollo neuro you guys know
we've been working with Apollo for a
while now it's absolutely I dragged my
feet Val first told me about it they
were like there's this piece of wearable
technology you can wear that vibrates
into your body and it helps you relax
cope with stress energize dial in all
that sort of stuff I just thought it
sounded too good to be true so I had one
in the box for a long time I finally put
it on the first thing I did with it was
meditate because what it is is as I said
it's a wearable piece of tech that uses
almost sub-perceptive vibration to speak
to your nervous system in the language
that it can understand and it has these
different settings energy uh Focus
meditate calm is what it's called now
that it used to be called meditate and
uh mindfulness that's called calm
because you updated but it's it helps
you ease into meditation that's the
first thing I did I was like is this
thing meditating for me it was
remarkable it helps your body relax it
helps your body sleep it helps your body
focus and be more productive it's
basically a wearable hug for the nervous
system using touch therapy to help you
feel safe and in control you can wear it
on the wrist like I do or on your ankle
it delivers gentle soothing vibrations
that train your nervous system to
recover and rebalance after stress it's
a wonderful way to get more energy It's
a Wonderful way to get focused It's a
Wonderful way to fall asleep that's a
huge help so many people having a hard
time falling asleep this is a chemical
free way to low your body body into deep
natural sleep it does all of these
things it trains your body the more you
use it the the better it works it's not
woo-woo they don't sell them in crystal
shops it's science it was developed by a
neuroscientist and a board-certified
psychiatrist and their effects uh the
Apollo's effects on stress sleep
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven in multiple clinical trials
in real world studies and me and Val are
no uh no exception to that we tell
everyone who listens what a big
difference these make so many weirdos
out on the road show me theirs and it
makes me happy because this thing has
really made my life better show your
support for your body show your support
of the show get 10 off by going to
apollonuro.com weird 10 off at Apo llo
nero.com weird alright everybody let's
get into Rory Scoville go check them out
roycegoovel.com get
into it
I just tested this morning it's not
unless Cove Cove 20. you got Cove I got
the 2-0 when's the last time you had it
coven yeah 19. yeah covid 19. what's the
last time you did The Cove I had it once
yeah and it was sharing a press tour
but a zoom breast tour yeah
and I Val and I decided to go up to Ojai
yeah and got a Airbnb this is before we
moved yeah because Val I don't know if
your lady your lady love is like this
Val is very like we should go to a new
space yeah like I'm I'm like a caveman
yeah I'm like Patrice used to have a
joke about we don't want to go out we
want to draw the blinds and like stare
in a corner just like replay memories
and be like should have should have
played that different and Val is like
she's like a pixie like in a field with
Daisy petals she's like let's go to a
new space to quarantine yeah and we did
and it was so small that's all I
remember was like I'm so big yeah like I
don't know if you classify me in your
mind is like a giant man but I yeah I'm
Giants I do I don't I don't
please don't do that I'm not saying
you're a dog yeah I know this is a great
comparison that big dogs they can't you
can't perceive yourself a certain way
for instance yes the the the similar to
this I am I grew up I was so small and
short and I didn't go through puberty
until like late in high school so my
perception of myself as a 5 11 6 foot
190 to 200 pound man yes is that I'm
tiny yeah can I
what what size are you in your mind yeah
is not what size you are right I dated a
woman I've said this before but I think
it's important and I mean this as
literally as you can mean something yeah
when she would yell at me and she was a
real she was a real bullwhip yeah she
should get me yeah should yell and her
eyes would turn black and just a little
Spitfire yeah I thought if she pushed me
I'd go flying like Superman right like
because I like you're a giant and I'm a
giant
her arm would break yeah
like a cowbell or what is it called
me with the ref dumbbells help me with
the Rev what is it it's a bell cowbell
not a cowbell
[Music]
four more kettle chips and kettlebells
am I right
kettlebell so kettlebell will you
quarantine in this place and I just
remember every door I had to like stoop
it was like an old ass Hobbit Hobbit
thing I'm Gandalf yeah yeah
the Barton Lord of the Rings where he
keeps yeah
and everyone else is running around with
meat and cheese platters and I got my
big floppy wizard to have my staff and I
am not and it really does is Gandalf
showing up just looking at them like you
got you guys can't come to my place you
fit in my place
you know re I don't fit in here
quit inviting me to your birthday party
I have it at my place why are we not
doing every chair is a throne to you
every bed is a is a California king yeah
why are you bringing to humans what am I
doing
yes my feet were hanging off the bed and
this is what I was gonna put to you
because I'm blabbing and boring right up
top yes I didn't do it I it's very easy
to make me feel I wish it wasn't true
but you can make me feel off-center and
just wrong yeah and it [__] with my
mojo like uh this is my question to you
what I'm going to do is stand up and
you're I you know I say this all the
time I don't want to make you
uncomfortable so I won't look at you but
you're if not my favorite I can't think
of who would be my favorite stand-up I
love that I didn't look at you look into
me
great comic great guy riffs smokes
doobies uh but I love what you do and
you're thank you you're a mo it's
incredible I actually I was listening to
your record on the way down
is that true yeah
yeah this is great yeah and I well here
comes the comp okay and I don't mean you
don't have to pay I mean I'm gonna pay a
compliment perfect oh God and then we
just sink in the couch and that's how we
died
they died in a riff they got eaten by
the couch it was a Pee-Wee Herman style
couch that was hungry did Cherry ever I
have to give a little [__]
it's just you are sitting on Cherry
you're suffocating cheers
look my name is perception Cherry's like
you perceive me to be a couch
I was born this way
I'm glad in your world chairs look like
me but in my world you look like yeah my
world I this is what we look this is
normal you're saying I'm a couch just
because I'm soft I bet Sherry hated that
they called her cherry yeah it's like
it's actually Bridget yeah cherry cherry
Sherry Paul she calls him Paul a subtle
dig really Paul
Captain issues on set stop using my real
name I don't want to be an actor I just
want to live amongst my chair people
it's like in I just watched The Edge of
Tomorrow Live Die Repeat and they're
like don't go because he keeps living
the same day over and over and he's like
so funny I just watched that recently
too it's really good right I think it's
a great sci-fi movie and I'm not a big
sci-fi fan and I love it uh if they're
paying for things in credits I'm usually
out yeah you know what I mean I know oh
how weird
[Laughter]
and beat it it's always raining you know
I feel see I'm cheating with you figure
it out you got flying cars you can't
stop the endless acid rain
you can't improve umbrella technology
the best they have in Blade Runner
endless acid rain
did acid rain ever take off did we ever
get acid rain I was I didn't you think
it was like dissolving umbrellas yeah
remember his kids I just said this the
other day as kids our whole thing was
watch out for the ozone layer and I just
remember as a kid you're always like as
long as we worry about the ozone layer
and we don't chop down too many trees
that was like the whole that was neither
of those issues the acid rains coming
and you're and then we didn't get the
acid rain
I think the acid rain was a thing it
wasn't it maybe was a thing I don't know
it didn't seem like it yeah I think we
would have heard about it we stopped
with the aerosols or whatever and and
supposedly the ozone layer has actually
like which rejuvenated itself Trump did
that thing where he sprayed hairspray
and he was like I don't care I don't
care about the ozone layer and people
cheered and as a comic I was like that's
like a 1985. I know look do do your
thing trumpy but that's hack I don't
care about the ozone layer and people
cheered that's what I mean it's like
that's bizarre it's like riffing in the
style that my mom and dad would be like
[Laughter]
because to them it was just yesterday we
were all about that ozone layer yeah to
you and me most of our Lives we weren't
talking about it but Trump's going in
the archives and being like I don't care
it's the ultimate staring at the sun
I don't care about the ozone layer yeah
it's such a Lewinsky it's Prelude
he's all over it yeah beautiful blue
dress ruined it now it's worth a million
buttons
like I am so when people can't say their
words yeah even Trump if he was like I
mean I like if he was fumbling my heart
would break free yeah I know it doesn't
matter I think it's because of what we
do it's because we know what it feels
like how naked it is and like botching a
joke boxing a word too soon when I watch
Chris Rock and he said because he didn't
get nominated for and he said the wrong
movie yeah yeah and then he said
concussion and I'm like I bet there was
a concussion concussion joke because you
got a concussion on Wheels and he messed
it up and he just goes I messed it up
I'm just like yeah I know I just can't
especially in that moment that moment
it's live and the only bit that anyone
cares about and you feel it I feel it
and I it's not cute yeah it's not funny
I'm not at home with my cigar going like
to be you yeah I'm I'm him yeah and I'm
peeing my pants it's that relatable
empathetic moment of like I know what
that feels like and the pressure and the
expectation is live see tripping I was
just going through my mind of tripping
tripping can be funny because your
body's so floppy and silly yeah but when
it's just words and it's like
that's not funny to me but when you you
stuff your toe on something and you and
you flop about yeah suddenly you're just
a corpse yeah a breezy corpse
flip-flopping on your way down that uh
that'll laugh at if you're okay yeah
yeah did you ever watch I don't want
anyone even Faces of Death Do You
Remember yes yeah what the [__] this is
surreal because all these things have
recently just come up edge of tomorrow
okay for the people that care I was just
gonna say remember he's like I should go
and just report that this is happening
to me and they're like they're gonna
dissect you yeah yeah that's always like
a thing right I forget there was some
way I tied that too I do tomorrow and
Faces of Death were both
recently because it was the like face of
death and also the original like MMA UFC
uh videos oh of like when UFC first
started when someone like hit someone
wrong and then it was like flop and it
was it was truly like you versus you and
it didn't the weight there wasn't weight
class they weren't it was just Styles
someone built a cage around a fight that
was already happening like someone was
showing up to be like I'm just really
strong and I like to beat people up and
someone else was like I'm five foot two
and I know Jiu Jitsu yeah and like
literally they just watched the mishmash
of who would win but Faces of Death yeah
I saw uh one of those and just it's not
funny it's not funny and it's it's
strange that there is this compulsion
and fascination
with it because it is so horrific and it
is Facebook we're all walking down no
it's VHS tapes yeah like let's say a
security footage got some guy falling
off a thing and getting hit by a car
yeah and it's like it's uh what is it
it's Taboo it's you shouldn't watch it
Extreme Tattoo isn't really discussed
much but it's a re it's as real as
butter on your bread it's like a biscuit
like you feel it like when you feel
taboo yeah you're not like I don't know
how I feel you feel [__] yeah
it's like we shouldn't do that it's like
that the board game Taboo it's like the
board game Taboo it's like the sixth
sense of like uh yeah of uh what is it
the like the
Umami
no taste is like taboo when you're
watching real footage of someone's last
moment yeah like what it made you fall
down a flight of stairs yeah I don't
want to see it there was one going
around recently where someone got in an
elevator but it was empty you don't see
anything yeah or somebody showed me a
video of a guy who was like a daredevil
he's like I'm gonna do pull-ups but like
off the world's tallest building yeah
and he just just goes straight down you
don't see anything right don't care if
it doesn't even as I'm saying it now my
hands are sweating I'm getting it too
[Laughter]
and here's an element that I think uh
because there are people that like don't
care they're very flippant about it and
also who is the world where they are
like they're like well people die or
whatever like think extreme things
happen and I sort of get their sort of
black and white about it sure but I
think there's personality types and I I
think I think most people are like this
that when you see it
and the guy drops you're going who is
his family what will they be told what
will that you know what I'm Easter
because we're we're all of us human
beings are storytellers but then some
people are like well I'm I do it
professionally
so then you're more inclined to go yeah
what did he have for breakfast what was
it like leading up there what brings up
there yes who's up there that's going
there goes Mike Who's down there that
saw Yes Splat yes Splat
and what I used to have a bit about that
with with uh strippers I I'm too in in I
I have to say this because people have
literally come up to me and confronted
me yeah and been like stop shaming sex
work and all that sort of stuff I'm not
yeah I'm saying it's hard for me to
invest in The Narrative of a stripper
and an erotic dancer yeah I just I'm
floundering I don't know what to say
just shoot me you shoot me and the
relief on my face
as you pass away thank you and I give
you permission you may air this okay
dude can you imagine that would be the
best way to die it's like you're just
floundering trying to talk about
something that where the language is
changed
you and you
emulate like a balloon that was filled
with panic and you just go oh thank you
thank you like at least this I know how
to do correctly yeah yeah yeah yeah
thank you
I don't have to pay taxes this year it's
hilarious yeah have you seen I know we
scandalized it's still a great bet
Louie's bit about
killing yourself I don't think so no
yeah it was very funny he was like
everybody gets one everybody gets like I
gotta go to work I gotta go to work he's
like no you don't
it's a very
very but IT addresses something that
we're all we're all on the knife's edge
yeah suicide I understand we take it we
put on a plate it's not funny yeah woven
into a bit we can find the the dark
release yeah yeah dark release yeah
anyway so I go to a a strip club
and the woman is dancing and I'm
thinking what did she have for breakfast
exactly what you said what what
breakfast it's right here it's right
there it's in here yeah it's being
gurgled and she's dancing right and
she's dancing but I never forget that
there's a colon bacon [__] bacon egg
Sando oh God now that's what I want and
what is her bacon egg and cheese that's
hilarious the guy who gets something
about the computer would you have a
McGriddle she's like just put your
dollar up here did you have a McGriddle
the weirdest we are the weirdest the guy
that's like oh yeah show me those necks
this is not weird
where are the freaks going do you have a
McGriddle I was always the guy that
would go what's your real name yeah yeah
like that's the [__] I don't do that
but that's the [__] creepiest thing
but I can't guess what's your real
Mercedes and she's like it's Destiny it
is Destiny
it is it is Destiny it happens to be hot
lips sir it's hot lips destiny Jesus hot
lips hot lips Destiny my social is 69 69
69 69. does anyone have that
does anyone have is it even possible can
you be four pairings of six is it
possible someone has all zeros all ones
like did they really start yeah
yeah like when AOL started could you
make it 696. what could you do that you
can't do yeah because you know the DMV
started making it that you can't make
things that when read backwards are
offensive because oh how clever we are
and horrible people starting putting
like Europe's like backwards right yeah
terrible words backwards because you see
license plates backwards most of the
time yeah like ambulance yeah yeah yeah
you're right like ambulance yeah one of
the most offensive words you really need
to be backwards by the way there's the
woo-woo there's the lights who's going
like but what is it let's investigate is
it a fire truck related
how am I pulling over with sympathy
empathy also only ambulance is backward
nope I know fire trucks aren't doing
this is It's the Most intellectual of
the emergency vehicles it's the smartest
one there's doctors in it so they're
like
like doctors like thank you for bringing
the patient here shouldn't this be
backwards because people see it if they
see it in the mirror they're gonna need
to read it and then the guy that paints
the ambulances is like ah Jesus Christ
yeah all right well bring all 100 back
bring all 100 ambulances back so we can
fix it
fire truck is based basically written in
crayon yeah
it's a wee-woo
Greg wewoo yeah and it squirts Wawa it's
the most basic well the fire trucks are
like what do you think we're something
else did you think we were something
else you thought we were a food truck I
think it's a very long submarine
Sandwiches yeah you think we're a
gimmicky food truck we're a fire truck
everyone knows yeah is your child into
trucks uh no not really baby she's seven
and a half that's not a baby I know it's
crazy that is the age uh this is a
little weird but that is the age that
they say that that innocence not it's
not a bad thing it tends to be
compromised yeah yeah and that is why
this is a fun fact I'm not Catholic yeah
Catholic fun fact that's why they
confirm at seven yeah because that's
when they're kicked out of the garden
they no longer again it's not a bad
thing it's not like I'm talking [__]
about your daughter not pure she's not
pure anymore but around seven boys and
girls both you tend to have some little
crack well it starts to happen the
facade where they go like yeah wait
everything's on fire well it's because I
think also because now out there it's
it's our influence on each other so now
she's more social she's in the second
grade yeah and you have other kids
testing the waters of you know
cursing or talking about something I
don't know I don't think it'd be sex yet
but like that's something yeah or like I
walk drugs or mention not that they're
doing it beer chip ice cream yeah like I
said yeah or mint chip yeah mint chip I
dropped Leela off at school she was late
um and I walked her into the classroom
and and she's such a sweetie pie she
wants a little transition time she
doesn't want me to just leave yeah yeah
so I sit in the circle and they're
singing a song that best of my memory it
was this morning I still can't remember
it was like uh two little monkeys in the
tree but it's not the bed yeah you know
this one yeah going sadly little
alligator can't get me
Alligator crawls up as slow as can be
snap
and then you deduct yeah one little
monkey up in the tree so they sing this
all the way down yeah we're having a
ball brutal murder uh yes yeah I'm gonna
be real with you by the way I was loving
it blood snap everywhere okay no way
it's not you're ahead of the story yeah
which I love at the end Renee the
teacher goes oh no one of the kids goes
what happened to the monkeys yeah and
someone immediate one of the other kids
goes they ran away and then another one
went they went swimming then Dean who I
love Yeah Dean by the way synchronicity
dresses like a fireman most days yeah he
doesn't need it backwards he doesn't
care he knows dress for the job you want
laughs
I can't believe I've never said that to
him there's a child I see almost every
day dress in the helmet and the jacket
and the boots and I've never gotten a
dress for that I'm a professional
comedian never occurred to me I just
went oh fun fire man well it's it's
jarring it is jarring
thank you back you're like yeah you feel
like Gandalf you're also is this
Benjamin Button was he a fireman
I don't want to insult a grown man aging
backwards yeah I don't want to insult
what could be a 90 year old man who
continues to be in the fire brigade he
calls it the fire brigade because he's
very old that's his that's his tail I'm
just saying Brigade I believe your story
I believe you're aging backwards story
yeah that that checks out yeah because
you said Brigade but um Dean uh we call
him Dean the Jelly Bean Dean the Saltine
Dean goes just anything that rhymes yeah
Dean goes they're dead yeah and
everyone's kind of like uh-huh and then
and then he goes blood in the water
blood in the water and Renee bless her
heart just goes like all right and like
let's move on all right Dean's right but
let's move on Dean's guess is the
closest accurate can I say something
Rory because this is the funniest thing
that's ever happened is Dean's right
that's the funniest that's every joke is
just trying to get to this joke the
truth of this joke that the kid is right
because he did just sing a song about
dying monkeys yeah one at a time they
have to celebrated it the last monkey
watched nine of his brothers get snapped
up did he was that a suicide but he
could have gotten to live without this
like I gotta go in yeah that would be
funny the last little mountain he
Wisconsin like guys should we get out of
here after the first one he goes I think
this is this is a bad situation this
isn't the place to hang these are
riddled yeah these waters are riddled
yeah with with alligators alligator
alligators
and I I just watched my dad die blood in
the water my whole family
Dean's right yeah that's like when kids
just point out how [__] up [__] is
good for him for also doing the math uh
very quickly with blood in the water
blood in the water that means he was
picturing it yes there's no line in the
sun this song is not easy for Dean
that might be you might have been at the
last monkey song that might not happen
again occurred to Renee like Renee's
like oh yeah maybe this isn't I think we
just retired the monkeys yeah yeah
but I mean uh because at least monkeys
on the bed they're just going to the
doctor and the doctor said no more no
more jumping on the bed you go to the
doctor and he goes this is pulp yeah
you've brought me the remains of what
was your brother yeah but I can't mend
pulp this yeah they're like what if we
bring in he's gone of nine monkeys
they're gone could you sew that into one
Frankenstein yeah we have
to avenge their death could they have to
be big enough like a Voltron of dead
monkeys to avenge and kill these
alligators but I've been I've been
thinking about that a lot lately the
biggest joke is like how hard and I
don't say this bleakly yeah but this
doesn't work look at that song yeah the
alligators you're eating monkeys that's
just how it is that's life that's it
yeah I'm not even saying like so that
excuses us it just it's just what's
happening Dean's innocence is already
erased that's it he's seven yeah
at the time it's like the dead blood in
the water the dean contaminated Waters
but isn't that what's cool about smoking
I'm not saying in fact I think it's
[__] disgusting I smoked briefly with
a girl who is that's very cool it is
very cool very cool is you're going uh I
know that it's blood in the water
everyone who's not smoking is going the
monkeys ran away the smoker goes there's
blood in the water yeah yeah they've
accepted it like when kids point point
out like what you ever see an unhoused
person with your daughter and they're
just like what is this yeah and we're
just like we just erased that yeah yeah
yeah let me teach you how to erase that
yeah we we or death or what a hamburger
is wee-wee yeah we talk about it we talk
when we see uh anybody out there
um that's unfortunately having to live
on the street or whatever the condition
might be like we chat about it and it's
Bleak it's Bleak I I have a thing of
like
feeling this is funny I had a I have
this need to just tell her the truth
which I think in its concept is right
and good yeah but there's an age for
certain truths and so yeah similar to
this Dean story We my wife and I were
like do is it time that we watch Willow
because I love Willow oh I was like
she's seven and a half and I was like
playing back in my head and I go when it
came out I was like I know I saw it in
theaters at that age yeah and I was like
I think I think it's fine and so we
start watching it going in the baby
carriage yeah so we turn it on and right
away uh the old woman is trying to
escape with baby uh Aurora or whatever
her name is steals a baby steals the
baby trying to protect her and the two
monster dog things are after her and
we're watching this and my daughter is
like a little Frozen
and then the they put she puts the baby
in the basket and puts her down the
river yeah and then the two dogs attack
the old woman okay and and she's gone
and we look over my daughter is pouring
tears so my wife goes turn it off right
now I turn it off and we we're like are
you okay and she was like she's like
what happened to the old woman and I
being who I am I go if they killed her
she's dead
I couldn't I couldn't not tell her the
absolute truth in that moment I was like
she needs to know okay look I'm with you
turn it off yeah part of me goes is that
the worst thing you can do because
that's death and you never got to
Resurrection you never got to see the
baby yeah but maybe it's not time well
my it wasn't time and my wife when I go
she's dead they killed her my wife was
like like I don't why buddy and I'm like
because that is what happened but then I
was like but also she's the first hero
of the movie I was like without her it's
all over I go it's all over without her
you go don't forget yeah the monsters
could have got the baby too yeah
I know and I wanted to be like I
understand the movie is called Willow
but it should also be called whatever
her name was because she really kicked
off any chance of saving the world it
starts with her it started it all and
not none of that is working she's like
why did they kill her and I was like ah
it's complicated but there's a lot of
fun in the movie we're like all right
we'll come back to this so now
any mention of Willow
uh in any context or anything about it
my daughter's series
buses with Willow my daughter's like No
And like I being me cannot help every
now and then just randomly in my house
I I don't have an example of what the
context of the conversation is but every
now and then just randomly I'll just go
remember when those dogs ate that woman
do your dog
that's it'll be like someone just said
something long pause and I remember
that's our job that's our job in fact
Dean is the comedian Dean is the
comedian right right like we're all
whistling in the dark to a certain
extent and the tune that comedians
whistle right is we're in the dark guys
we're in the dark we're in the dark like
yeah this like instead of denying it
there's a pleasure in leaning into blood
in the water it's blood those dogs ate
the woman I think we have a thing where
we do you know where it's my wife always
be like if I said something to my wife
and a friend is over
and I'm saying something that I know
that they'll like laugh at and then they
laugh and my wife will be like don't egg
them on don't you've heard this we've
all heard this like don't don't be his
audience and I think what is so funny to
me is that like even when there isn't
the audience like me saying randomly
those dogs remember when those dogs ate
that woman it's because I know if this
did have an audience that would kill
kill yeah but what's so weird and I
think what we get misinterpreted and we
get labeled psychotic and I don't think
it's totally off is that my wife is
there going just but you're saying it
and there isn't an audience and I'm like
I I know and you you can't be the
audience because it requires you to go
because I want to be in the audience and
this is what I want to watch something
[Laughter]
I want to see that in a thing but is
there anything worse
I don't know is that me
is there anything just making sure
that's up
is there anything worse than being like
those dogs didn't eat that woman because
she saw it I know and she won an ally
that goes like they were playing with
her
she wanted to play yeah they were having
fun they tickled her in the very next
scene someone gets stabbed with a sword
is that she's never seen that before is
that true no but it's coming up yeah I
remember the orangutans like the
orangutan preachers the whole thing is
that mardigan steps in their poop yeah
[Music]
yeah I remember watching Beastmaster
when I was like yes eight yes and it was
I bet even younger I bet you saw it even
younger than that I bet I did because
remember there was a time when it was on
HBO or TBS all the time it was all the
time and I remember I had to talk to
someone about it and all I remember was
there was this one scene where there are
all these guys in big leather cloaks
like like they look like death yeah grim
reapers and someone runs and they run
into one and right before they hit it it
opens its arms hugs her and then lets
out a bunch of Goo yeah like just digest
yeah yeah what was I thinking I know and
then the like they forgot about that I
ran into the weird boy I always needed
the weird boy yeah you know the weird
neighbor boy yeah I say this with love
Yeah he was just kind of like he was a
dean yeah blood in the water and I'd go
like blood in the water and I'm over
there trying to be I don't know Dennis
the Menace yeah like I got a slingshot
I'm trying to that's how I'm whistling
through dark but I need Deans yeah and I
found this Dean and they go I saw this
and he ran and digested him and you know
what you're kidding you're saying it's
like it's awesome yeah but underneath
you're also like am I gonna be okay yeah
and the kid went sounds like you thought
beefmaster and the relief
the relief that he had also seen it he
seems okay and he knew what I'm saying
is so much of my life including this
conversation is going like there's a lot
of blood in the water out there and I
don't just mean tragedies yeah I mean
sometimes I think about how the my
battery on my phone is just slowly dying
yeah I'll be pushing Leela at the park
and I I remember like I have a tile like
that key ring yeah tell me and I'm like
pushing her and I'm like gotta change
the battery on my [__] tile and I
just kind of go like God damn it yeah
like this [__] doesn't work everything
that's alive is slowly
and that can be what it is yeah but I
need to find a couple D in the saltines
and be like blood in the water right I
need I'm not even destroying to yes and
you I get so much comfort when someone
goes like remember when those things ate
Theo ate the old lady yeah yeah because
otherwise we're all of the psychic
energy required in the denial of death
that energy this is ramdas now I'm just
quoting Romulus without saying it he's
like can be used in other things yeah it
can be used to like enjoy the moment
yeah so when you say remember when that
woman I go oh right we're all sort of
[__] yeah right we're all just sort of
like collapsing the acceptance of it and
then all that energy I was using to push
the beach ball underwater I just let the
ball out and now I have that freed up
energy to be a silly [__] to like clown
around you know what I mean right like
not just deny but like why is it
virtuous I also can't watch them
suppress it I can't like like I remember
we were watching uh season two of mine
hunter and I think it was episode two I
think and they discover in the basement
like this is where like a kid was killed
and like that episode ended and I told
my wife I was like it's just now
occurring to me I'm shoving all of this
into my head I go it's not already there
yeah I go I I get it I'm also attract
it's like like the the Faces of Death
yes there is an attraction to wanting to
see this extreme thing even though you
don't want to like it's why people say
you can't look away from a train wreck
or you know what I mean like it's right
there is there is humanity in wanting to
see the thing you don't want to see I
also think there's a deep psychological
level where we're attracted to death
because we secretly unconsciously think
we're guilty and deserve it I think
there's something going on yeah and also
should be annihilated the fact that when
you don't know when it's coming you
don't know what it'll be like yeah
yeah
I think it uh I think like that like now
imagine that all you're ever watching is
like faces of death and I was like oh
this is what we're doing we're always
watching these crime stories or always
watching something dark
handmaid's tale and then you're like let
me throw on even something like Breaking
Bad where you go yeah but you can
separate from that story you're still
watching this anxious heavy yeah you're
still watching something heavy and and
you're putting in your brain and I
I think it's why I don't really watch a
ton of stuff because I think for it to
be good it neat it does need those
things you need to like make me go oh
[__] yeah you need to do that yeah and
yet so how many shows am I gonna watch
where I step back and I go you know at
the end of the year I watched you know
700 hours this many hours of tension of
hard imagery let me what do you think of
this I think it's an extension of your
brain's [__] up idea that dwelling on
things helps you know how when you're
anxious about something yes and it's not
helping and there is no solution same
but it's like one more time around the
barn yes one more time around
it's embarrassing Being Human if you
could see how many times I'm like this
is helping that's what I think so much
of the news is that's what I think so
much of horror movies I I almost watched
a horror movie last night because we're
getting our butt kicked with Leela she's
just rocking us I feel like I've been
sick how old she's uh four yeah she's
not like four and a half I guess yeah
yeah I've been sick for what feels like
nine years yeah she just brings home
fresh disease yeah yeah like Christopher
that's I didn't mean a small box I
didn't I didn't I was trying to think of
like a voice it did come out that way
but it does make sense that didn't pop
into your head as outlandish like it's
not outlandish I was trying to think of
an explorer that goes to places and
brings back diseases we didn't have
that's what I was going for but your
daughter is Christopher Columbus you're
doing this all teaming it right now
because you're going blood in the water
did that happen yeah yeah that happened
and we're in taboo we just tabooed
that's a taboo yeah but I wasn't trying
to make light of that but I've been sick
for like six years
um well four years constantly sick ever
since she's been going to school for
like two years yeah and like she just
doesn't sleep uh and we're just getting
rocked so last night I came as close as
I've come to watching the knock at the
cabin yeah because I was like you know
what it was I used to think that people
that watch horror movies I'm like oh
these depraved not really yeah but let's
let's give this voice it's due these
depraved like sort of low class low rent
idiots
to be titillated need to see like
someone's jugular drained in real time
like that's the only thing that'll get
their attention yeah you can't just
watch The Bourne Supremacy you need
someone's eyelid being peeled off by a
clown yeah and then roaches being fed up
their nose or whatever the [__] I but
last night I was in such that's also
specifically I know that was very
specific I was in such dismay that I was
like I know I want to put this back to
you parenting is so much harder in in
ways that I didn't expect yeah that at
the end of the day I'm so drained that I
was like no I want to watch a horror
movie because my own State yeah sort of
like ground up sick tired and really
what it is is a feeling of hopelessness
meaning like there and it's gonna be
this way tomorrow yeah and it's going to
be this way for and then she has two
weeks off and then it's just gonna be
like by the way I I do what it says
lovely she's my life yeah she's my life
yes and last night I was like I'm either
gonna eat an entire Pizza yeah which I
didn't do and I'm proud I'm still proud
of that yeah or I want to watch M Night
shyamalan's knock at the cat I want to
see Dave Batiste to be a scary neighbor
yeah yeah yeah because I was like
that'll be so uh bombarding yeah that I
won't be thinking about my reality it
actually made me this isn't virtue
signaling it made me understand why do
people love horror movies it's probably
because they're having a rough time the
escape the Escape yeah yeah it doesn't
Ted lasso by the way last night val did
the best Ted lasso burn she goes I'm not
watching the new season and and she was
like Ted last I was like you know that
feeling when you eat a jelly bean and
you think it's cinnamon but it's
actually cranberry it's like that's that
whole that's that whole show and
everyone's just kind of like yeah it is
like that it's like it's that feeling
when you want to Reese's Pieces but it's
a Skittle it's actually a limit schedule
you thought it was a Reese's Pieces
better wake you up in the morning all
right Ted that's not enough that's
that's not it's not enough
for a lot of people
at the end of the day for it's not
enough people oh for a second I thought
you were just a short neck giraffe
that's nice enough they need guts and
blood and screaming yeah because Ted
lasso in a windbreaker being like
someone needs to die someone needs to
die because I'm not distracted Enough by
a man in a mustache being like Oh I got
a nose Tickler yeah you know when you
get a no Tickler you feel like you're
gonna make sneeze face it does feel good
though when that is enough when you're
like this is plenty during the
quarantine that was plenty it was plenty
that was plenty I think that's all we
wanted because the life life was a
horror movie yeah so we wanted I think
I'm more that I'm like give me just a a
smatterer
of entertainment yeah I don't need I get
it I don't we don't got to go too deep
no granted I love the deep I love those
things
you know what I if I'm on a plane give
me what you got but if I'm at home and
and my wife is like let's watch
something I'm like I don't want to now
if you said here's a 15-minute episode
of I think you should leave yeah then
I'm all in and I'll watch the whole
season right now yeah but if you said
let's watch the exact same amount of
time of this very well done mind-blowing
drama I'm like I can't digest it it's
too much you're full I can't do it I'm
full I have a bed that is so it's it's
I'll just say it it's inspired by you I
go you know why I won't cheat on Val
because I'm full I'm full it's not the
Fidelity it's not even that I'm not
attracted to other people it's that sex
is only part of the night the rest of
the night she's laying on the silk she's
going like I've always been afraid of
the sea get it out of here get the [__]
out of here I can't listen to any
stories about your childhood I'm full
yeah yeah and that's how you feel yeah
about TV with movies and shows that's
how I feel about Game of Thrones when
they're like I'm from missildor and I'm
like I don't know I know I don't know
where the valley is yeah I've lived in
Los Angeles for 20 years yeah still not
entirely sure I want to do something
better with my time like I think when I
say I'm not going to watch something I
do feel like I'm making a good decision
mentally yep um but then I'll just
[__] Doom scroll Instagram and I'm
like I wish I would go read I wish I
would do anything more beneficial can I
I'm gonna offer something yeah you want
to want to read yeah does that make
sense
yes it's not that you want to read
because you don't yeah you wish
you know when you I want to walk because
then I would do it yeah all right great
now we're doing it but those moods that
we get in where your brain is rested
usually when you're rested yeah and you
have a little time yeah sometimes I have
I'm rested and I have time and I just
I'm staring down the barrel of 12 long
hours alone and I do dick yeah and some
days I wake up and I feel like a a young
uh Thomas Edison I'm just like fertile
yeah and I read so what I don't really
want free time I want to want to live I
want to like I once took a micro at this
house I took a micro dose of LSD and I
got in my bathtub and it says tiny
little bath I was wearing my pants I got
in my bathtub noted it's just like if
you saw that in a movie and a guy took
LSD and got in his bathtub in his pants
he'd be like it's not really like that
cut to me wearing pants in the back but
only because you're like I saw this once
I'm mimicking television
and I'm aware of it it's because I got
in the tub just for the sensation of
getting in the tub yeah and then I was
like just turn on the water yeah I was
like one of those Beautiful Moments
where you're like pants can get wet yes
like would you [__] lighten up yeah
yeah that's exactly the feeling yeah by
the way it's like this freedom of like
yeah oh pants can't get wet yeah pants
can't get wet yeah really yeah and then
Val came home she goes I'm full I'm just
so full Honey Pants can get wet Pete
I'm going out
I'm going out she's going did you watch
that did you watch that SNL sketch
called uh straight straight guy friend I
know that's hilarious introducing
straight guy friend and he's just like
he doesn't talk he's the best part is
he's like uh you tell him you're going
out of town for six months and he's like
you gotta do it live your life he
doesn't care at all that's what Val will
leave and just find like a ham and egg
yeah regular guy that's just like hey
and she'll love it instead of this
madman in the tub I love that but when I
was in the tub I was like you don't want
you don't want uh to take a bath you
want to want to take a bath yeah like
the feeling of Freedom yeah and anything
is possibleness is actually what you
want does that make sense and it's when
you're in that place is when you could
read you could take a bath with your
pants on it kind of doesn't matter
you're just aware of the infinite
potential of every moment and you're
hungry for it as opposed to scared of it
or retreating from it yeah that's what
we're actually after does that make
sense yes absolutely I have been doing
uh extremely cold showers okay and
welcome to the show only you're the
first guest to bring up cold exposure is
this three foot five I'm not I'm not am
I no I always bring it up oh I'm a huge
cold exposure I I have been doing it I
have not had a hot shower outside of
like sensory deprivation tank post
shower it's hot all of my showers have
been uh just cold water only tell me
everything and I it has changed my
discipline on everything I've gotten off
coffee I've gotten almost completely off
booze but I was I was hard on booze way
down on both I thought of you as a booze
I I mean because I'm not like
belligerent I'm not like a drunk or
anything but like literally wanting two
cocktails a night because I'm bored and
I'm like this will make me happy the
making the drink the drinking the drink
while jazz is playing in a candle's lit
I want this space yeah so I'm addicted
to what it is yeah
um ritual uh pot I've been do I the last
time I got high is a month and a half
ago really yeah all of these things
um because of cold showering well I
wanted to get it just cuts off like the
like the finale
next week
I've been doing some cold plunge been
doing the cold showers and it's it's
gotten me to discipline in those other
things and tell me what is your theory
on that I think it's because the cold
shower
one being mentally and physically
beneficial I was not sleeping for like
two weeks and I'm not and nothing I'm a
great sleeper but this was an extreme
and I was like I know that I'm not
physically active enough I know it's my
diet I know it's anxiety about this tour
coming up I know it's anxiety about many
things many stresses and I I was like oh
I I'll just focus and try to get some
sleep it wasn't happening and then I
just said I I need something extreme and
so I went to take a cold shower and it's
awful who told you I I've you know on
Instagram you see posts and stuff about
it so and also I've seen funny for all
the evil and I'm with you for all the
evils every once in a while it goes like
hey this will change your life
yeah I follow a lot of like painters and
I get on Instagram and I'm like I get
when people Doom scroll but I'm Legit
this person made a video of how they
made this painting and I'm in I'm like
If This Were a TV show this is all I
would watch yeah and to the point where
I'd be a couch potato yeah yeah I love
watching even it was just pictures of
paintings I'll watch that but the cold
shower getting into it uh was miserable
the first four times and but I made
myself do it so I was very proud that I
made myself do it and I didn't talk
myself out of it because I'm so good at
that that's the whole thing and then
after the fourth one I found myself kind
of craving it and having a little bit of
an addiction of like as you're talking
about it I wish I would love it right
now yeah like waking up in the morning
I'm like I can't wait to
first thing I get all the shutters open
and I make I try to make sure you know
my daughter I go in her room and open
the windows and turn off the sound
machine the night light to let her
slowly wake up and I do the same uh in
in the bedroom to like get people kind
of stirring and then the stupid and let
out a little
bit just to get rid of the scent be like
hey that'll move that'll Inspire motion
as they get out of here just a little or
a good catchphrase of ah brother and
then she just gets under the covers uh
but I get into the freezing cold uh
shower absolutely love it in there for
less than a minute I'm taking I'm still
doing shampoo I'm still conditioning if
I need I'm still doing soap I'm doing
I'm doing what you do yeah but I'm in
the shower and I'm getting better at my
breath under the cold conditions but I
am instantly wildly energized yep and
because of it that good feeling makes
you go well don't lose this good feeling
and you know how you'll lose it is uh
you know eating too much meat or meat in
general eating too much sugar or sugar
in general I I've heavy booze yeah I
don't need caught once you do those cold
showers you realize you don't really
need coffee I still go to coffee shops
and I get a decaf and I used to make fun
of people that did that being like just
why are you coming here and spending
money because I still like the
candlelight and making the drink I like
what the space I like what it is though
human beings need cues
life is learning to tolerate and merge
with and celebrate uh what is the word
turbulence like like discomfort yeah so
I I'm huge into this and every morning
when you do it you're you're setting a
standard of like I can teach my body to
not Retreat from discomfort and go and
get I know this is like kind of a cliche
but like get curious about it yes can I
mind over matter this yeah I just had
friends visiting me this past weekend
and I was like let's get in my cold
plunge they wanted to yeah and it was
guys and guys are usually everybody can
do it obviously but men in particular
more than women that come to my house
want to get in the cold plunge and I
love that I love that I've never been
like very identified with masculinity in
general yeah but I was like this is
awesome like we're gonna do this kind of
like weird rite of passage yes three
dudes yeah and it was raining so it was
like a Scottish morning overcast yeah
cold plunge if I'm on your back porch
it's over here yeah past the pool yeah
it's right by the the hot tub yeah yeah
yeah yeah you saw it and we got in it
and I tell I always tell people the same
thing I'm like you have to tell yourself
you love it yeah so like which is crazy
but you know what No One Believes No One
Believes you when you say it takes 10
seconds of confidence and courage yeah
because after 10 seconds you will be
shocked that you're fine yeah and that
your breath is it takes especially
especially in the shower breathe deep
breathe deep breathe deep yeah and you
go okay and we're fine that's absolutely
right the shower is harder than the cold
Plunge getting the water all around you
I go to like here yeah getting the water
all around you makes it easy easier to
cope with than little bits of the water
torturing it's a little more torturous
very interesting yeah but it's colder
yeah a shower I think only gets to like
it can only get so cold it only gets so
cold I get it I'm a connoisseur yeah I
go to hotels like I'm shooting this
thing in Toronto
the Toronto cold water yeah [__] cold
Bliss it's so cold it's real snow and
you it's real it's melted it's from a
glacier it's from a glacier it's
cascading Glacier shavings that they
slide into your bathroom and you know
the colder it is the more High you get
yeah so this is like a really and I
always tell it's like a healthy
addiction and in the cold lunch it takes
90 seconds they say before you are not
in pain yeah but like I don't think
that's true I think it's so much faster
how cold is your cold plunge it's 98.
it's a hot tub
[Laughter]
where I'm
where I'm with 39 you get in 39 yeah
it's supposed to 90 seconds it's
supposed to be 39 right yeah
um and how long are you doing it well
now because I'm so used to it I have to
go five minutes so because I've read you
need 12 total minutes a week Cube
I don't know who said it huberman did
you know who I meant when I said to you
no it's some doctor she said yeah yeah
12 years was quoting him I heard it was
11 or 12 per week do you do that do you
try to stick to that I do so look all
these owies and I do when I get in the
cold place
I can't do coldy shall we there's blood
in the water it's blood in the shower
Dean blood in the water when you uh I
have to do five minutes and then I get
in the hot tub yeah uh and it's it I
call it the full body jizz everybody
knows this they've heard me talk about
this before yeah but it's the best
feeling in the world I will do so right
now because we're gonna buy the cold
plunge yeah I've been getting in my
unheated pool during the winter there
you go and it's been great it's
definitely not in the 30s I'm certain
but it's cold yeah yeah I've gotten very
good at getting in I set the timer and I
sit there motionless meditative
breathing through the nose nice and deep
four minutes four minutes and I do it
three times a week and I I get out I
make sure the towel is on my back porch
I don't have anything near me and I stay
in the wet and the cold which is now not
cold because you're now actually getting
warmer right and it's very bearable
um I get out and I try to stay in that
for as long as possible because it's
also uncomfortable although you get out
when you get out because I don't love
being wet I'm gonna give you another
just and then we'll move on because some
people are like I'm not gonna do this so
you talk about this every episode no no
it's I'm just thrilled that it came out
because I'm talking about it yeah they
say move so even if you're in a cold
plunge oh move around you hold still
interesting you build a thermal layer
yeah so if you really want to make it
difficult which you do around you have
to move so if you're so incredible the
last time I did it I was inspired to
move around I was like I really should
get in here and swim yeah you shouldn't
I'm gonna do that next time yeah I love
that and so you got off of all of those
things let's talk a little bit about
that yeah because I was interested in
your relationship with weed and I also
want to talk about your painting because
uh people well we instagrammed it I
don't know if everybody saw that but I
love your painting so much
it's a part of the tour yeah this is our
Scoville we love it so much it's really
a joy to me and then I also want to talk
about
balance like Showbiz life balance
because I think that's one of the things
that you and I yeah when I talk to
people I'm like I don't really know
anyone that is as
um you could say actively pursuing some
semblance of balance in the strange
industry yeah or you could say
reluctantly involved in Show Business
and like self-promotion all that stuff
yeah we'll talk about that but when we
come back we'll talk first about weed
because I'm very interested in in cold
showers and then your relationship to
that now so we'll be right back
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at Sunday's food for dogs my dog
Brody absolutely loves Sundaes and I
love Sundays because it is healthy dog
food that's actually easy to store easy
to serve and Brody absolutely goes nuts
for it it makes me feel good to see him
so happy and to know him taking care of
his body what is Sunday Sundays is air
dry dog food made from a short list very
short list of human grade ingredients
Sundaes was uh co-founded by Dr Tori a
practicing veterinarian it contains 90
percent meat 10 vegetables and zero
percent synthetic nutrients besides USDA
beef and all natural chicken you'll find
digestive AIDS like pumpkin and ginger
plus disease fighting antioxidants dog
parents report noticeable Health
improvements in their pup including
softer fur fresher breath better poops
that's a big one for me it's better
easier to pick up I'm gonna add poops
and more energy I also love that it's
basically like having a box of cereal in
your pantry but it's a air dried great
human grade Quality Meat for Brody that
I can keep with no Refrigeration in the
past we've tried to get them premium dog
food it took over our freezer it took
over our kitchen and it was nasty this
is like pouring him a bowl of cereal
couldn't be easier and it's still fresh
dog food with zero prep zero mess and
zero stress it's shelf stable makes it
easy to feed your puff top quality food
and every order ships right to your door
so you'll never worry about running out
of dog food again which let's be honest
is a huge pain in the butt Sundays also
cost 40 less than other Healthy dog food
brands because Sundaes doesn't waste
money shipping Frozen packages not to
mention all the waste in the packaging
there instead you spend it on what
matters sourcing the best all natural
ingredients for your pup we worked out a
special deal for weirdos get 35 off your
first order on Sundays go to Sundays for
dogs.com weird or use code weird
checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s Dot com
forward slash weird upgrade your pup to
Sundays and feel good about the food you
feed your dog all right everybody let's
get back to Rory's novel
and we're back and we're back do you
want to drink that that's for you that's
a magic mine speaking of what does this
mean good what do you mean what does
this mean it's you shake it if you're
gonna drink it shake it it's just 35
milligrams of caffeine so it's like a
cup of tea oh maybe I shouldn't because
that's what I'm trying to get off of all
caffeine with the coffee yeah all of it
yeah 35 yeah I'm 35 years old you are
not no 42. I'm not gonna do it that's
fine but I I love this bottle it's got a
little I love the name yeah okay you
don't have to love it no I do I like
this subtly sweet you know how much uh
uh isn't like coffee it doesn't like
it's not like putting uh car jumpers on
your nips yeah it's very mild but anyway
this interior improvised album which is
called live yeah it's both it's kind of
both because of the um uh uh
uh I guess the album will be called live
but the documentary special that we did
is kind of use of both because of the
documentary part of it about the thing
about Bob Wood and the relapse theater
right yeah
in the track I didn't know you put in
these sort of like sketches it's really
funny and it's very telling that the the
uh White Noise radio I love that you
listen to it because it exists out there
and I feel like no one listened to it or
there was just no word about it I I
didn't want to I didn't want to title it
the same as the documentary especially
it was on YouTube and uh people were
like no people should know it's the same
and I go but while it's the same concept
it's not the same material about 75 is
not the same as stuff that went into
that thing you know yeah it was I I
don't want to make you feel bad but it
was also not easy to find I know
it kills me you mean that's right I'm so
happy I was like I know there's another
I had to go on Apple music to find it
yeah some reason Spotify was like you
mean this old Spotify took my stuff off
yeah I think they maybe put it back up I
switched over to title I was like you
don't pay people I'm going no title oh I
didn't know it's a little more it's a
little more expensive but Jay-Z I don't
Almighty Bart Coleman got me into it
okay and I was like I'm gonna go title
they pay the artist so really yeah oh
okay I should write that down I just
remind me at the end anyway so in the
interstitial the the DJ who is the DJ
Ben Roy uh it was the first one yeah
it's very funny and he says uh you know
uh Rory is improvising his record and
he's very high uh has a drug problem and
I was like that's really interesting
because you wouldn't we don't make the
blood that's a blood in the water joke
Rory you also say he's improvising isn't
that just a lot of talent that's also
very lazy it's like this way of calling
out yeah like on one hand and I I think
I understand all this because I I like
to do stand up in the same in a similar
way than you do yeah it was like yeah
it's remarkable it's also lazy yeah um
and you're stoned but do you have a drug
problem so where are you at with with
weed now I mean I I will say and maybe
people who do drugs always say this but
I don't think I ever had a drug problem
I certainly didn't have any drug problem
with mushrooms because it's too much
work it's too much mental gymnastics
that could be addicted to like facing
their relationship with their father in
the form of a cloud right yeah yeah like
who's like let's do that every day let's
do it all the time it doesn't work right
yeah if you do it on Monday on Tuesday
it won't work right like you still have
the antibodies I believe yeah and then
uh you know so I never had an issue with
that and then pot and these are the only
two drugs I've I've really done but pot
I I have and did smoke for a very long
time I remember I saw you at
um comedy what is it called The Outdoor
one
supernova supernova yeah so there we
were and I hadn't performed in six
months you hadn't performed in six
months yeah uh or whatever it was
lockdown yeah and I'm nervous you're
nervous and and I saw you spark up a j
and I was like
I sometimes my jealousy yeah gets
filtered into incredulity meaning I'm
like I can't believe he's doing this but
then there's also a part of me that's
like I can't believe he's doing this so
it's like both but there you were Rusty
yes going on stage Stone so back then it
still had a certain magic yeah I mean I
think the magic is still there I still
love it I still love going on stage uh
high so very much it's it's a lot of fun
but it's also you get two different
products and I think I I think both
products as arrogant as a sound I think
both products are good I think when I'm
high
um for the most part when it's good I am
more exploratory I will I know yeah go
I'll take turns I would have never taken
that sometimes are good for right then
and only right then yeah sometimes the
perfect sentence comes together where I
go that is now in the ACT forever that
is great and then sometimes it goes
nowhere and you you tank a little bit
which you're also likely to do with
being sober and have written out a great
hour you know you can still tank it
right so you know and then if I'm sober
I'm a little tighter and I'm a little
more in the in the uh mind frame of of
spotting callbacks and remembering what
I was just talking about and if I do go
off on a tangent I remember how to get
back to where I was or if I'm high I
can't go back right and the best thing
for me to do is just keep going down the
road and just let that be the show and
then well this is again something that
you've influenced in me is like
don't get scared
that it didn't go anywhere yeah because
if it didn't go anywhere that is the
joke yeah right I mean you and I both do
that you and I also do so we have the
same blind spot and I think I already
told you this because I I recognize it
in me when I saw you at my last Largo
sometimes you'll forget or I'll put it
on me and I know you'll relate no this
is right I forget a key line a key
element yeah and then I start going into
the bit because I just can't wait to get
to the funny part yeah but I didn't say
like in in your special you sorted do it
it totally works out yeah but you don't
say that a self-driving car yes killed a
person yeah you just say these computer
cars hit there was a fatality yeah I
know and it's like kind of like I'm with
you because our brains are wired the
same I'm like okay I'm gonna I think he
means this and the audience is with you
and like only like three quarters of the
way into the joke which then becomes the
joke meaning the joke is that the
comedian kind of forgot to be clear yeah
yeah and that is titillating and a
delight yeah so it's not a criticism no
a self-driving car hit a person is that
did you guys see this article but you
and I both Val will be like Pete you
forgot to say it was the president who
sent back the tuna melt right yeah and I
just start going like are you guys here
are you hearing yeah what I'm saying and
then but here's here's the the true
government is in that album and whenever
I watch you
it's such a like it's such a golden
sword you've pulled out of us out of the
stone for all comedians to learn from
and Berlant does this and and Bo does
this there's others that do it but it's
like what's happening is okay yeah and
you go like you do like it didn't go
anywhere and the instinct to the
performer is to let the audience then
win yes and make you sweat and be like
well I wish that was better yeah but you
go like imagine if that's my special
it's just a series of meanderings you
keep opening the door and thinking
they'll be and it's empty it's as empty
as your grave and like you just dig into
it does that make sense yes absolutely
and that is that's what I this is the
compliment I was trying to pay in the
first half I was like this is what Steve
Martin would be doing if he if he kept
at it yeah he never became a movie star
and was just pushing the edge of stand
up I think that's a fine company I think
that's a great compliment I appreciate
it that way when I watch you yeah I I
think I I enjoy uh uh the joke's not
working
um I don't know when that clicked when
it clicked that the joke's not working
is also
a really fun place to go and I think and
I don't know when it clicked it's a
spectacle I don't remember who I saw
where that that moment of inspiration of
realizing oh it's all
it's all it's all just the show I think
there I think it particularly this is
the show yeah I think there's something
in when I went to uh the first time I I
did uh Dublin and I opened for Dylan
Moran uh it was at the the the Vodafone
at the time Vodafone Comedy Festival and
I was you know he was one of the he's a
huge name there he's a huge name in a
lot of places but he was a huge name
there and I you know I I didn't know
much about him I didn't really know him
and I was like oh we're in this bigger
tent he's clearly a draw I'm doing like
15 minutes to kind of open it up so I
did my 15 minutes it was fine I had a
lot of fun I went into the crowd and I
watched and I I as he walked out
uh this guy yelled I love you before he
got to the microphone and he stopped and
like looked at the guy and he had a
glass of red wine also something I
hadn't really seen a comic going with
yeah and he took a consumers red wine
put it down she doesn't talk to anybody
yet
and just goes but what is love really
and I was instantly like
I don't think that's a plant I don't
think this is his act I think this is
all right now like I believed it and I
was like because the the he's making
this the show he's basically he's like
I'm gonna get to where I get to but I I
have something I can say I have an
opinion I can go into this and he goes
into it and this particular guy who I
really believe was a genuine fan
every now and then would yell out
something like I love you again and by
the third time this guy yelled out I
love you and Dylan Moran was like he
goes I know he goes but he goes the
reason we won't ever work is because you
don't know how to share me and that one
sentence made me realize
that I was like oh all of these tracks
all of these like oh and this is where I
make a joke about why Alice In
Wonderland's a weird movie and then from
there I say I I the bathrooms are crazy
you know like all the things that and
I'm not trying to rip on those topics
those are those are fine topics and I
love them you're canceled for putting
down topics yeah yeah but in my head I
was like I keep looking at the show
as as though I am doing a set and that
isn't the show the show is its own
living breathing thing and instead of
going could you not Heckle I have an
agenda instead why not have this Heckle
be part of the show be part of the story
there's so much to gain from it and it
just made me realize it it wasn't the it
made me realize take a deep breath and
quit acting like this is a surprise yeah
and instead perform as though you fully
expected
the sound of Pop you fully expected a
phone to go off you fully expected these
things and make this the whole room
because everyone is experiencing and
hearing at the same time and the last
thing they want you to do is to yell
because a glass broken like come on can
we keep the like they don't want that
yeah don't be the drunk Dad driving to
Disneyland yeah God damn it right I'll
turn this car around all right let's go
to Disneyland let's go to Disneyland
there's a detour be chill we're still
going to Disneyland yeah it's all you
had to pull off the road and pull back
on my friend John saru food who taught
me a lot about acting in college told me
a story I don't know if it was him I
don't think it was him he told me a
story about seeing someone playing
hamlet in some renowned theater like the
Globe Theater yeah
and it's the to be or not to be speech
and here's the guy he's Hamlet it's the
moment every actor dreams of and the
crowd is riveted and he's about to say
to be or not to be and some woman and he
was clear he was like this woman wasn't
drunk or disruptive she was so invested
she said audibly to be or not to be like
you know you know what I mean she's like
to appear not to be like she she was
like that's how she was participating
with the show and it kind of slipped out
yeah and instead of being mad this woman
just stole the greatest lie yeah from
the greatest play for the greatest actor
and he gestured to her he didn't pretend
he didn't hear her yeah he gestured to
her and continued the monologue without
that line as if she said it yeah he
rolled with it yeah yeah he was like tis
nobler and just went with it yeah
brilliant yeah that's it yeah that's the
whole thing that's what I got for me to
teach the audience go like being like
what are they good I'll say this I got
into this into comedy and art because I
even though I'm sure people were trying
to listen to me I didn't feel heard or
seen and the longer I got into comedy
the more I realized oh I'm now
comfortable enough on stage to see them
yeah I like pay it back right like
you've looked at me enough now the show
is actually going to be and I say it on
all the time on stage you go you're
watching me I'm watching you yeah like
like you guys are doing okay you know
what I mean that's a very Rory kind of
thing yeah but like to to call out
this is our show yeah we're making this
show together yeah and when I see
someone just doing their act to me
that feels like a drunk relative
who has purple lips yeah and isn't
reading the cues that I'm an
eight-year-old boy and I'm uncomfortable
with how much spittle is hitting me
right yeah yeah you know what I mean yes
that is that energy that unconscious
energy that so many grown-ups gave me as
a boy was what compelled me to go like
let's get into a fever pitch right of
light and sound where ideas are heard
and then with that power you can start
giving it back and then ideally at the
end of the show everybody feels like
they exist yeah does that make sense yes
100 I think it makes it uh you know the
the goal being how do we make everyone
feel like they are right here right now
and it's not like hey come to the sit
here and get like lost in this it's like
get here and just remember you're in
here you're not out there and I think
that's that's what's so disturbing about
uh the the you know it there's more to
like not wanting people to film because
you haven't really worked on the
material yet you don't want the the
people to film because this is maybe not
about your being able to tether this to
out there to later that's for me to do
if I want to do it if I want to film it
if I want someone to make Clips out of
it if I want to do those things but the
whole thing is we're right here right
now it's why it's why I'm willing to bet
95 of comedians don't really like their
specials because they don't feel like
what what it actually is and what you
actually do and I think the I say this a
lot and I do I do believe it even though
it's coming from someone who doesn't
have the experience of playing gigantic
venues but I think the bigger the venue
the more separated I feel on my couch
like yes I do actually want to see how
you perform and what you do in a regular
at Madison Square Garden I do want to
see it and I do want to sit there and
wonder what does that drug
feel like and how fun is that paycheck I
do want to know that I do want to know
who's calling it what it is yes I do
every seed was fifty dollars yes quick
math yeah I would love or more sometimes
100 plus I want to know what that feels
like to get that paycheck I want to know
what it feels like to have those people
I want to know is it annoying to know
the people in the back think you can't
hear them I want to know if you can
actually get to a point in your set
where they are all quiet like a pin they
could hear a picture because they are so
invested I want to know if that I want
to know about that stuff but
when I am watching on my couch if I
really want to connect I really believe
the thing that a comic does if it's
filmed in a smaller venue I think it
does translate better better the person
on their couch like I do understand you
go yes but if I film it at a notable
theater and I'm not saying I won't ever
try to do that if I do do it but when
you do it that's that's its own version
of entertainment but when you do it at a
jazz club yeah you know Sarah or like
you know how Gerard uh Gerard's last one
you do feel more like you are at it yeah
and so you feel like you can connect
it's my own personal opinion you can
connect with it in a different way
because you think you're there harsher
yeah I've watched a lot of great hours
make an ego choice for a big venue which
is just uh oh look I can't know it helps
sell tickets I get there's a promo to it
I get it yeah but to me it feels like a
a trophy like I did this and I filmed it
there yeah and then you compare yourself
to the other people that did it there
and you're like and I did it yeah and
then you see like a bigger version and
it's like
I don't know was that the best yeah was
that the best but I'll also say venue be
damned maybe I'm completely wrong and
you can do a great special in a venue
that is seven special audiences right
yeah yeah maybe you can yeah what I
would say then is the job of the
comedian is to and every time I do a
special I try very hard to do this
is is warm it up yourself get into it do
something to disrupt it because they're
nervous yeah you're nervous everyone's
aware that here's the special version of
this bit Yeah that's the enemy of comedy
and that's what's so great about your
specials is like can we throw that away
when did we turn this into a firing
squad like yeah I'm gonna stand here
nervously and and hope I get the wording
right yeah I I hate it I hate that
element of it because that's not what
for me that's not the product that I am
making or that I do I there is a little
bit of fun going hey don't improvise at
all and take all these jokes and try to
write them as tight as possible I do
love the idea of going I've gonna I'm
gonna try to write it so tight I'm gonna
drop things I love that I get this many
people laughing at yeah because I want
to now see can I write it so tight that
I am literally gonna do 60 Minutes of
hot this like I mean hot to wear it's
insane like I I I'm I'm trying to do
that right now for this tour that's what
I want to try that's actually my
favorite Rory I love riffing Rory yeah
but my favorite Rory is when you're
doing today
those bits because you're doing it
you're still the same
and when I say clown I mean you're free
like a clown you're still doing it
you're still in the room yeah but like I
love the bits yeah I want the bits I I
love them and actually like sitting down
I mean this is what's bizarre is that I
just this week
went and sat down to really take a look
at what this tour hour might look like
it starts in in two weeks and I just
went and sat down to go all right all
right I know I'm gonna open with this
and then so quickly I looked at other
jokes I've been doing for years that are
just like quick little things and I was
like
oh this actually goes right after that
and it would be boom boom oh and this
actually follows that like started
putting the puzzle together of going oh
I've been concocting yeah all of the
ingredients I just haven't actually sat
to see how where do they all fit in the
recipe because and it's fun there's a
lot of specials I watch that are again
some of my favorite people to watch live
and you watch them on tape and you're
like I wish they had put the puzzle
together a little bit more I know I'm
kind of talking out the other side of my
mouth I was just talking about stay free
stay loose have fun yeah but like
those first five minutes can we make it
can we make it [__] great can it lead
to a big a big yeah because you're
telling the audience you can trust me if
you yeah make the mental effort to start
picturing what I'm saying and locking
into the premise that I'm introducing
laundromats are sexy I don't care what
you say yeah okay if you if I say
laundromats are sexy and everyone's
going okay I'm gonna I'm it's it's not
like you're studying but you are lending
effort yeah and trusting and then it
just ends with like I just like [__]
socks right and then you go like they
subtly learn like well it's not really
worth it I'm gonna pay less attention
yes yeah yeah I so I'm both yeah I'm
like be a silly being but I love that
you're doing this because when I want
when you do my Largo show and you are
like the Arnold Palmer yeah like I'm
gonna riff around I'm gonna be silly
right I'm gonna make fun of Pete I'm
gonna make whatever yeah yeah and then
I'm also gonna do
I'm sorry to keep talking about your
titty [__] joke yeah I love it
I'm like that's it Rory where he can
riff and knows that he can do the bit is
my favorite Roy yeah I I I love it uh I
love the ratio of it I love the finding
that Arnold Palmers are great great way
to [__] describe it well he always
dressed in two-toned colors yeah what if
that's whatever and then I just go with
it right
right that's what I thought you were
referring to when it comes to Showbiz
and painting something that you and I
have talked about in life the
humiliation of of touring promoting how
difficult it can be when it's not
selling out and the stress yeah and like
I even have stress with this podcast
it's such a wonderful gig but it's like
booking guests and yes and making sure
we have episodes yeah we've never missed
a week that maybe we've missed one week
with a repeat or something but like for
the most part for 10 years I know it's
crazy it's been when you really start to
think about it you're like oh this is
insane and it gives me a lot of pleasure
like I love Banking and just having a
couple yeah loading them in and it's
both that's a great feeling I love doing
it this is such a pleasure for me it
really is yeah and there's also stress
of like how are we gonna and then you
get the advertisers and all that yeah
there's all this stuff similar stand up
so funny I'm gonna give you this thought
sometimes I go like I can't I can't
touring is just so stressful yeah and
then I go if if we were touring like our
friend Nate yeah bargatzi yeah and every
city 10 000 people yeah we wouldn't be
like this is a drag right you know what
I mean yeah it's just the vulnerability
of you put tickets on sale yeah and
there and and it doesn't sell out or
you're just worried that it might not
sell out and then if you're like me I
guess I I will
ingest that somehow I'll be like well
we had a good run yeah you know what's
so interesting and I I know that this is
true for you too but I speaking for my
my for myself
like I know that if I would just hit the
road
it would be I just know it because of
the repetition and how I am it would be
the best I ever was I think in terms of
just tight Fearless confidence was in
2006 after I went on the road in Canada
and then did the Seattle comedy
competition right after and I ended up
doing three straight months of Road
where I was performing every single
night
I came back feeling like a Jedi and that
early in my career I remember going oh
it's it's repetition if you if you are
funny and you know you're funny the
jokes are gonna come but hitting that
level of confidence was the first time I
was like oh I don't even need the jokes
I'm just gonna start talking and do
whatever and make it [__] work and it
felt so powerful and so because I know
that's in my mind I know that if I would
get up all the time uh and hit the road
all the time I don't know where I'd be
or how I'd be doing I think I probably
would be less worried about like how are
the tickets but right I don't love it
enough to go out and and do that doing
other things yeah I'm also very much
like I do want to be on a TV show I do
want to be in movies I do want to write
a script I do and I understand the
people who hit the road hard also end up
in those places doing this things but I
you know I also want to direct I want to
produce I want to see what that whole
side of that world
is like
and I also want to keep doing stand-up
but I don't want to just hit the stand
up yeah it's so hard I'm not driven to
do it I'm not saying if I wouldn't hit
the stand up all those things wouldn't
happen they maybe would but I'm just not
so driven to want to have a new hour
all the time I mean it's why I like
going up and saying hey I'm improvising
this whole set and it isn't so that I
will for sure go listen to it later and
pick out stuff that is very much great
material I could work on yeah but
instead I I will sometimes go that was
that was tonight and that's where it
exists and it's only tonight and there
isn't a recorded space of it and I like
that those people experienced it and
maybe they will be fans or maybe they
they won't be but yeah yeah I I like
that there isn't some
uh uh there isn't some work to be done
about it I'm with you man there's
something also it's a life philosophy
too and that that is where I don't I
wouldn't say I'm at odds with it but
like
so that I told you there were three
three friends staying at my place this
past weekend and it occurred to me at
one point I was like these are some of
the most interesting people I know let's
record a podcast and I was like I
decidedly was like let's not record a
podcast yeah like I didn't mention it I
know what you mean because it was like
this reclamation
I haven't done psychedelics like a big
dose of psychedelics in a long time but
I don't need to to have the revelation
of like not every element of my life no
matter how much the culture would
encourage that yes should be
removed from me and then placed in a
bakery shop window like yes as as much
of a here's the other side a privilege
it is that people would like to see you
do stand up or you or me to stand up
yeah or sell whatever idea or thought I
have there's something
you kind of have to this is the I say
this a million times but this is the
sell your soul
uh story yeah that's why that endures as
we know there's a cost yes and it's not
just
you know the volume of the other areas
of your life get turned down when every
night you're you know hanging out yeah
Bon Jovi
but like when you were in that tight
spot where you were the best you've ever
been yeah
I'll speak for myself the times in my
life when I'm like wow I'm performing
every night and I'm bulletproof it's
really hard for me to enjoy a sandwich
like I just wanna yeah I just want to
decapitate audiences yeah yeah yeah and
count and just keep going and keep going
and going look it's become a machine
yeah and that's very appealing and I'm
not saying that that isn't super fun at
a certain point though and this will
bring us into your painting
is that that relationship with you in a
canvas has to be pretty pure right I
mean yeah you're not getting a laugh for
doing this yeah you're just listening to
yourself yeah I have to imagine you're
listening to music probably it's
probably mentally uh saved me in a major
way because it's the first thing I've
done that has not required
any validation uh you know I mean
everything I have ever done it is
validation is required or it's the
reason the reason I'm doing it the
engine of it and I for this that was
that great imagine if you could time
travel but you still do stand up like
going to different eras and still being
like I'd like to feel so desperate
approval in this decade yeah it's so uh
it you know and and I don't hate it I
love chasing that validation I love I
love uh I love it I do love it it's a
part of who we are just forgive it yeah
meaning forgiven meaning don't judge it
yeah it's okay right yeah yeah it's
honest yeah it's how we feed our
families yeah and it's and it's really
cool that our psychological you could
call it a deficit or you could just call
it a soft spot or whatever also happens
to be valued by our culture and feeds
our families yes 100 so we don't be sad
about that with the with the painting
which I've always been very drawn to I
think I I got into stand up or the thing
that I was attracted to in stand up
because I wasn't a musician I wasn't in
a band I can't sing all that stuff
but the idea of like the 60s uh beatnik
culture Bob Dylan Greenwich Village the
traveling singer-songwriter the the the
Jack Kerouac poet novelist like I love
the the Arts artsy idea of this
traveling artist who has their thoughts
and they don't need a I love that
stand-up needs a mic yeah not even
always I love that it needs a stool fine
you don't have one but it just needs
whatever you thought of that's either in
your back pocket or it's already up here
and it's just you talking and that the
full product doesn't really require a
sound check it doesn't require it's it's
I love that it's Bare Bones travel
around get on a stage or not if there
isn't even one and and give the product
that is you
two people I love it and I was always
like oh that's what that's what really
there's something I always was attracted
to about that and it's what makes me
love uh the road and it makes me love
this job and what I realized I I didn't
realize until till a couple years ago
was that the attraction I really have
had that I never paid attention to was
painters and and more so than the
singer-songwriter traveler is that I
think painters just seem to be the
coolest people like a photo of Picasso
in like his underwear in this massive
space with all of these canvases that
are you know yeah who knows what they're
worth at that time but you know now that
room is a golden castle that's Fort Knox
yeah and he's just sitting there with
like a cigarette being like oh this one
I did that five minutes ago because I
was bored and you look at it and because
it's Picasso so he was like yes this red
paint there that's a painting I love
that
I love that that but he can be a thing
because he got into his Seattle comedy
competition place of reps right yes and
and removing all of the doubt and all of
the impediments yes to actual artistic
expression something naked something
vulnerable right the thing that really
took me that really that pushed me into
realizing all this was you know growing
up when someone showed you abstract
paintings at least for me I was always
like oh [__] oh okay so that's that
they smeared some paint like what this
isn't a painting and never felt like it
was a painting now I think it's more of
a painting than something that looks
like a photograph to someone's like no I
took three years and I painted this I'm
like not interested at all I'm
interested in this thing that's just one
color and it's right through the middle
and there's and it and they maybe did it
in less than 10 seconds right there's
something I'm so much more attracted to
and because of that the artist that that
that that come with that and the imagery
of them I just thought
they they there was something so cool
about them their Aura they're almost I'm
not here to play by your rules and I
don't [__] care that you think this
is [__] yeah this is [__] genius and
I'm a genius and I there's something so
attractive about that confidence as
we're all attracted to confidence but
that particular kind really really had
something for me and so
that made me go I I want to make
something
and then step to the side for someone to
take a photograph and you can see on my
face that I'm not here to ask you if you
think this is good yeah you can rip this
up it won't change how I feel and I it's
so interesting that a bad joke
that doesn't work even though I know is
a good joke and you you we have these
you'll do a joke a hundred times you
cannot understand why it does not work
as well as you think yeah it should
because it's so good and even though you
still believe in it you have to some you
have to come to terms with the fact that
the audience does get to decide yeah a
little bit and with painting
someone could say it's a hundred people
the same amount of people that don't
like that joke could tell me that this
painting is so bad and it's awful and I
just would constantly look at and be
like
I don't know I like it I there's
something about it that I'm into and it
can't you can't harm it you can't
penetrate yeah that feeling and so that
space has just been so fun to go into
knowing that it's this freedom from
validation that I didn't know I was
craving so much and I think what I love
is that I love this painting validation
freedom and then I also love stand up
where the audience does get to decide
it's a little bit did I bomb tonight is
this good like I kind of like it's more
of a thrill you can have both yeah it's
interesting uh I have two questions for
you one is a comment actually it's it's
that that to me mirrors the spiritual
path to me spirituality is about finding
a um causeless Joy something that just
is more sturdy yes so this mirrors that
100 you're finding something that's a
little bit more honest and not I was
just thinking about this the other day I
was like it's just this talk about a
premise that wouldn't work it's so weird
that I'm a corpse like I'm a dead person
Dead Man Walking yeah I'm I'm not long
for this I'm gonna go yeah and I perform
for other corpses and if they hate me
I'm like God those corpses hated me do
does that make see I can't I can't even
really make it hilarious corpse is very
harsh I just mean these impermanent
things yeah are feeling feelings as if
what's happening is gonna last forever
right when it doesn't right the
meaninglessness of it it's and the
freedom of the meaningless not this the
dread of the meaningless yes but Eckhart
I've said this a million I'll say it
every time I think it though Eckhart
Tolle suggests watching some sometimes
just set up a camera in Times Square
around the turn of the century sometimes
a uh frame correct it so it's not fast
and they'll colorize it you can just
watch dudes in bowler hats with
mustaches and long coats and Canes
walking around Times Square and you're
like what were they all worried about
yeah
all each and every one of them there's
something they're a little like I have
to get to the exactly I think the same
is the same as now that's it that's what
I'm saying they were worried about the
same as now just their version of it
that's right yeah and you can watch and
go like
go and
go into an apothecary and bike free
cocaine or not that's silly right but I
mean like live your life yes yeah why do
you care it's different what I'm saying
is
what is it it's like an ice sculpture
caring about another ice sculpture
thinks it's not a beautiful ice
sculpture and they're both just melting
yeah like what a waste of your ice time
yeah you know what I mean yes so your
pure relationship with yourself yeah
which is really what's happening yes
you're painting from you're a deeper
part of you yeah let's not say deeper
but a d a true part of it I think it is
I think it is a deeper play it's very
meditative it's very uh honest it's very
honest and it's also it's not easy in
the sense that it isn't the do I have
the ability to paint do I understand
painting do I understand what colors to
use or shapes it isn't any of that the
entire exercise is can you get out of
the way yeah can do you know how to step
aside
and stop thinking about is that right is
this is perfect this is this where it
goes all spirituality yes that is what
spirituality is saying yeah is get out
of right wrong yes no good bad and just
let the sediment Settle yeah on your
awareness or in your case in your
painting and let it be but then the
evolved thing that we're all trying to
do is I do affirmations every morning
that might be Corning but one of them is
I'm a beloved child of God yeah and that
is like that's a good I have to remind
myself all the time right yeah yeah and
I know that's religious language that
might not be you could say I am at home
in the universe I belong here yeah I
deserve the space it's all the same it's
all the same yeah yeah but when you
paint something and you're not worried
about what other people think about it
I I find that profoundly spiritual
here's my it translates too it
translates in the sense of like uh
um
I you know after a painting I remember
the very first time it really hit me and
I was I was painting out in the garage
and I was interested in it but it is you
know when you don't know technically
what you're doing it it's frustrating
and you and you start out by thinking
that you're trying to make a painting
yeah but you're not you're just painted
you're not making a painting you're just
painting you're not there's not there's
not meant to be an end product it should
just be an exercise right and so I went
out to the garage one night so very
spiritual by the way this is yeah it it
was like uh a little over a year ago
um and it shocks me how many paintings I
did in a year that I really like because
it it isn't who I've been for 40 years
and then suddenly I'm very dedicated to
it
um
but I uh I went out to the garage and I
was a little high and I put on an album
that I I didn't totally know it was uh
um uh ladies and gentlemen were floating
in space
um and I put it on and I I wrote that
it's uh spiritualized interestingly
enough okay and I I I've always loved
that song but like I've never listened
to this whole album I'm gonna put this
album on I'm a little high I've got a
cocktail here a glass of wine something
and I put down a canvas and I just put
like some paint on the canvas and I had
uh like a one of those like little like
knives that you like um they're like
knives really but yeah you know you pay
enough and I just like smeared across
and then I just grab all the color of
smearing across and I did it and I
naturally came to the end of this
painting as the album was ending and I
put it up on the easel and I looked at
it and I went inside and I told my wife
I was like I think you should come out
here I go I think this is the best
painting I've ever made in my life and
we went out to the garage and she looks
at and she goes yeah it's fine it's good
and I go and I and and I love that that
was a response she was like yeah it's
fine it's good and I I'm still looking
at and I go
I love it no I love it and that was the
first time I wasn't affected by the fact
that she didn't love it and it was like
the handcuffs were coming off going yes
oh good I'm not here to make I I'm glad
you don't like it and or love it and I'm
glad you're saying yeah it's fine I'm
glad you said it's fine it's because it
challenged me to go
because I could have been gone well what
do you think it needs or what and
sometimes I do ask that because there's
uncertainty about a painting that I
clearly don't know where it stands but
to look at that one and go no this one's
this one's good and I really love it and
I've shown it to other people I've shown
this painting to people who [__] they
love it they go oh that's great I've
shown it to people that are like what
else do you have and I'm like this is
this is the it makes me so
happy because then when I do a painting
that I maybe don't fully believe in it
makes me step back and go quit thinking
you need to fix this because remember
half the people hate what you love and
half the people love what you hate yeah
so this to somebody is maybe great and
it's easier for me to now go all right
that one is for sale because I'm not
trying to keep it you know right but
there's something in all of that but I I
loved every moment of that I also think
it's funny this is back to bathtub and
pants
everything is a mirror
and I've used this example before but
Val and I were just having this
beautiful day when I think it was before
Mila was born so it was just like more
of the dating time the hanging out it
was all about us
and we watched the movie why him Brian
Cranston and James Franco I don't know
it oh wait I do know it yeah yeah that's
sort of my point
we've got a lot of buzz on the movie why
him yeah yeah
and it's fine yeah but we were so in
love
and just so happy
that we watched why him and we were able
to project our own Joy onto this movie
yeah that didn't
abuse our joy and ruin it it wasn't like
so bad that it [__] on it some art can
do that yeah but it became a vessel for
how we were already feeling and if
there's anything
art music I've had that a lot and I
don't know it it can be so disappointing
you play someone a song that really
matters to you and they don't understand
it yeah
but you're not even really hearing the
song you're re-exp like what I'm saying
is you painted that painting you had the
record you had the weed yeah yeah like
even your story it's like if you
what I'm saying is your experience
imbued the painting with something that
wasn't just on the canvas yeah and
that's everything yeah it's Wilson the
volleyball I'm not trying to be funny no
I get it it's like human beings
you can make a totem you can make
something you can make a rock precious
if it if you tell a story this is again
we're back to strippers and and what
breakfast I can get into sports if you
tell me always comes back to Street and
the breakfast and the McGriddle but I
can get into sports if you fill me in on
why it matters and what it means and
like if somebody tells me a certain pool
move it's really hard to pull off and
then you show me the first guy that did
it or whatever yeah that's imbuing it
with value and sometimes you just show
someone doing a pool move and who
[__] cares yeah yeah yeah
uh I want I had just had a moment of
self-doubt where I'm like I don't think
I said anything
I don't think I said anything new I know
I said something but I'm like I think
people know that yeah people know that
yeah have you ever you haven't done the
pod in a long time and I love your
paintings by the way maybe I'll
Instagram the one you're talking about
when this comes out but have you here
the new questions that we ask great have
you ever almost died have you ever seen
a ghost
uh you can tell me about a great nap
you've taken oh man that those are all
so different
um I did uh sensory deprivation tank
yesterday and I think I've done them 15
to 20 times total and yesterday was the
best it has ever
been ever and I liken that too an
incredible nap because see I was Elaine
there
you think you've ever said that just
laying there and just feeling so good in
the the the the Blackness and then the
warm water and just floating and feeling
so great and I think I put the earplug
in a little too far
and I it was hurting me a little bit and
I started to get like a little bit of a
headache and I was like I think this is
attributed to what is being what this
earplug is doing and I was like ah it'll
be fine this let's try to just work
through it
in about five minutes later I was like
nope it's it's over the nap this space
this comfortable space is over because I
have to get up and deal with this and I
gotta wipe my face off got out of the
tank where the shower is
and for about 10 minutes could not get
the ear plug out because everything was
so slippery I was drying everything off
still so slippery drying this doing
whatever I could salty slippery too
salty slippery could not get anything
dry enough to where I could get a grip
to pull it out and it's every time I try
it goes in further it's going a little
further so I'm having to like limiting
efforts that I'm doing yeah and then
finally I got a grip and pulled it out
and it was I was like oh it's so funny
how I went from this Blissful piece and
in my head going hold on to this it when
you get out keep this keep this and yet
here I am going oh my God yes my ears
gonna bleed and I'll never hear again
and then I'm just taking a shower and
I'm like already right back God damn it
this world doesn't work this world
doesn't work it's a clue yeah it's a
blood in the water yeah uh Byron Katie
calls that the thought that kicks you
out of Heaven you're sitting in a
hammock and there's a Sunset and the
birds and it's perfect and you go
what if I had a cocktail right now and
that is the truest yeah yeah that is the
truest thing yeah um I love that answer
what was it like before it was ruined it
was just great I was in that warm
comfortable space of like not really
feeling
myself but like you know eyes are closed
and you're just you're lost and I wasn't
like hallucinating or deeply meditative
but you know you're it's just you you've
done it I'm sure yeah you're in that
deeply kind of meditative space where it
just you feel so good it's I I it feels
similar to when you're in bed and it's
early enough that you don't have to you
don't have to jump right up but you're
like I don't want to get out of yeah bed
yet and I've got 20 more minutes and you
just feel oh God you just gave me so
Blissful and you're like this is what
you almost I think when I'm especially
in the tank I'm like this is the closest
to being back in the placenta and the
womb you just reminded me my mom used to
put these flannel sheets on my bed in
Winter and I remember
I think I got up to pee because
something needs to disrupt it to
recognize it yeah I got up and I
remember I just I can really feel it
wasn't worried about anything yeah and
got back into the softest warmest sheets
didn't have anything to get up for any
reason to be anywhere yeah and I I think
I've been chasing that of course it's a
yeah I I loved I that that just feeling
that yesterday then being like oh this
[__] yeah that's Dean the saltine
coming in my ears dogs ate that old lady
that's that's exactly right that's what
it is never forget dogs eat people
that's pushing my daughter on the thing
and going my tile battery is full yeah
he's gonna die right it's gonna I'm
gonna have to get new flat those like
Little Nickel batteries yeah am I gonna
get one of those yeah
loud going who gives a [__] Dad push me
yeah exactly push me I think it's so
funny how times were so clear and other
times we're so murky yeah just so have
you ever seen a ghost
I don't think I've seen a ghost I don't
have a ghost story that where I feel
like that was definitive Definitive but
you know what I you don't have this
brain I know it for a fact I have this
brain where when someone goes have you
ever almost died or have you seen a
ghost I have maybe had those experiences
but as soon as I'm asked them no no
they're gone I do have that brain yeah
and I relate in fact a big thesis of
this show that I've never stopped to
like write out or give a lot of thought
is like let me tell you in the hopes
that it'll make you think of one because
it's so much easier than people have
something Point Blank right because
somebody was
somebody in this conversation I was like
I've never seen a ghost and then I
remembered that every time I go home to
my mom's house in Arlington the ghost of
her cat jumps on the bed and I was like
oh yeah I guess I do have or that story
where you're almost sudden you're like
life isn't always in fact let me ask you
this you know that feeling maybe you get
it on stage I'll tell Val about my show
and I'm like I could see the Hall of
Records that is my brain and I could
open any card catalog and find any word
any thought any ideology any metaphor
any example that's my favorite place to
be and then a lot of the rest of the
time I'm just like what is it called
yeah I know contact lens yeah when you
can't think of a word on stage we're
back to where we started worst ozone
layer yeah
um well don't worry about it how about
the hardest nothing I didn't even have
to say that I kind of acknowledged that
you had failed yeah don't worry about it
up until that point it was fine you're
forgiven yeah
that's been a big thing lately it's on
it's on a isn't it up there it says
forgiveness yeah it's on the Post-it
note forgiveness is overrated is what Dr
uh doctor father Greg Boyle said on this
podcast he goes because forgiveness
acknowledges that you did something yeah
Mercy is where it's at yeah Mercy is
like what do you even
what are you talking about yeah all
we're all just ice sculptures man yeah
I'm just melting it's fine like don't
even it's gone can you tell me the time
you laughed the hardest in your life
I just uh
I was uh I I just told the story but I I
was an altar server at a Catholic School
and great start they would pull you out
of school if they needed two altar
servers to work a funeral that was
during the day and I was in sixth or
seventh grade I think six maybe and they
pooled myself and uh Archie Gallivan uh
out of school I knew before you said it
that it was going to be a great name
yeah Archie Gallivan Archie Gallivan
yeah of the Gallivan printing press yes
and we we are the two uh Ultra servers
and uh the funeral is happening it's not
open casket or anything but you know
it's it's it's very small
uh let's say like 30 people and you know
they're the everything's good it's
happening whatever the funeral is and uh
the reason this is fun as an ultra
server because the one thing they will
actually pay you for like they had to
pay and the church gives you like 15
bucks so it's kind of a big deal and uh
RJ sitting next to me there's two
stained glass windows uh that are across
from us you know the priests here facing
the church and we're sideways and
there's two small stained glass windows
up here
and one is Mary holding baby Jesus and
just looking at Baby Jesus and in the
next one Mary is uh looking down on you
know assume Earth or whatever and her
arms are open like this and Archie goes
doesn't it look like she just dropped
Jesus
she's like
like though
and I look at this and then I look at
this and I it's two panels can't not
laugh it is he kind of laughs I am like
I'm doing like
like trying everything but you know the
more you try not the more you are
because it has to get out and I cannot
laugh the priest is beat red angry
people over here are in mourning
of a someone who has died in their
family and they are like in shock and I
he's like Archie is like you've got to
stop you've got something I'm like
oh my God I'm like literally like doing
that wildly audible the church is very
quiet outside the person speaking which
is still quiet
yeah so other noises are so audible you
could hear a mouse and I
I I I will always remember that as one
of the times that I maybe not the
absolute hardest I laugh where I got
like a headache or like stomach pains
but one of the hardest types of laughter
where I couldn't get it under control
and I couldn't just take the deep breath
and go save for later don't look this is
me the whole time I'm like my eyes can't
not look up there and go God he's
absolutely right
so much so that at my uh sister's
wedding in the same church I'm like
pointing it out to people and I'm going
doesn't it look like and they're like
yeah it does it looks like
finally in a safe place but it's not as
funny because you real that's a funeral
laugh and I but it caused me to like
tell people that story to be like hey I
got in trouble sitting right over there
like this James Morrison just did this
and we were saying that church the
bringer of the best laughs yeah in
history yeah yeah aren't in comedy clubs
right it's all of them having asked and
you can't let them ask people this
question you have to contain them it's
only my I've told this it's not a good
story but mine was getting a tour of a
library yeah in college yeah and the
woman kept saying and this is where we
keep the professor's Theses and I just
thought that sounded too much like the
professor's feces see you get it and as
if she knew that's what I was Finding
funny yeah she kept saying Theses yeah
and the various Theses are stored is
airtight so the thesis can't get out I
was just dying laughing
libraries churches funerals yeah quiet
spaces you say that to me just in a
field yeah maybe uh that kind of sounds
like feces yeah yeah yeah and it's also
tour academic tour first day of college
funeral it matters yeah yes we should do
a comedy special words because you and
me whispering to people at a funeral
like we shoot a very running gun and
you're just sort of like have you ever
known
and try to get people that can't laugh
yeah laughing or just pass them pass
them a note pass them a note and they
like read it
they start losing it I'm gonna say this
is a genius because it doesn't even have
to be that funny yeah yeah yeah which is
great for me right
same well Rory I I remember the question
I was going to ask you which is why do
you like the painting with less effort
but I don't know we don't have to do it
we can end uh yeah I don't know I love
it I just love it as like it's what I'm
able to do and enjoy and it makes me
I've taken a painting class to try to do
profiles uh and on with oil and it's I
would love to be able to do it
but I'm just more into grabbing some
paint and just seeing what happens yeah
you know I guess there's more room for
your participation the less the artist
is doing too yeah I I maybe this is we
should have ended but who cares it's
like when I'm a big turning point for me
with art was realizing that my reaction
to it is correct yeah that is CR like
instead of wanting to cheat off my
neighbor's paper sometimes it's fun to
know the history of a painting yeah or
what they meant by the painting yeah or
can you have you noticed the play of
this this and this and oh he's violating
oh primary color Zone oh Picasso did
this one oh that's all blue or whatever
yeah but when you look at an abstract
painting instead of thinking of it in a
very commercial materialistic achievy
Western way I could do that you can just
be vulnerable enough to remember that
sometimes when your eyes are closed
depression is just a swirl of purple or
like a speckle green yeah and then when
you look at a painting it triggers that
in you and you can't even really
articulate it but it makes you think of
the first time you went to the dentist
and you were scared yeah you're like
that's got to be wrong how could he have
known that or she have known that they
didn't and here you are having the
experience can you have that by looking
at my couch yeah and art is a a space
where we've
isolated and welcomed that
type of Engagement with reality yeah
doesn't say you can only have it with
art but it goes like let's make this
just like you can't only think of God in
church a museum is like let's just have
this be a consecrated space where you
can let something speak to you right yes
a pay phone can also move you yes or yes
your car or your I was making a smoothie
this morning and I ripped the lid off
the the protein and like the it made a
wisp of inside yeah yeah and I was like
that's as beautiful as anything I've
ever seen in my life exactly that's
that's bath with your pants we just wish
to be alert to that level and art
invites us to be that way yeah all right
I guess I just I love that I wanted to
say some [__] I guess I love it I just
worried I didn't say anything
[Laughter]
drink the magic man what the [__] is
wrong with you yeah
I'm like a weird aggressive we just
shrink it
35 milligrams of gas is wrong with it
the [__] is wrong with you I thought we
just talked about that I am never gonna
see you and not mention by the way how
long have we known each other rafifi
yeah yeah New York yeah yeah I actually
until this month five times ago forgot
that we were in New York at the same
time yeah yeah I've known you and been
with you in La for so long that that
feels like that all that's happened but
there's been the bulk the bulk has been
out here but there was I was in New York
so long I have three and a half four
years which I mean is a long time but
it's not I kind of wish it was longer
kind of wish I stayed longer but but you
went on stage and it it really affected
me so I'm going to mention it every I'm
sure I said it last time I'm sure I said
it last time and I'm also sure you don't
remember
you went on stage
for like you go but what is love this is
my version of that story you get on
stage and you go does anyone have a
Viagra because I need to get hard right
now
and you probably said that 10 times
and if you don't find that funny I don't
know what to do with you but if you do
the tenth time you're saying it yeah
there's something is really funny about
a pill that gives you a biology like it
shouldn't be a natural response and
embarrassed about yeah yelling about it
publicly yeah yeah so there's two benign
violations there's two jokes happening
right but it's also just the third but
not the third joke is the joke like of
all the ways you could open you're
yelling at the crowd yelling does anyone
have a Viagra because I need to get hard
right now also fourth joke why does he
need to be hard he's about to do stamps
yeah you never talk about it either you
don't give some reason no yeah that's
super important right if you had been
like a big boy come back is this at the
end like it would almost get too dirty
or weird but just never and how much
like look I'm using that bit as a mirror
to me but how much of life is acting
like something is normal that isn't
normal yeah and that is it's absurdity
that helps me go like that makes as much
sense as so much [__] that we're acting
like right makes sense and that's weird
and now I can laugh it's just yeah I'm
always going to remind you of that bet I
love it all right would you say keep it
crispy is there any bit of yeah
keep it crispy
[Music]